Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Las heladeras están vacías.
Los baños, mugrientos.
Hay ropa tirada por todos lados.
Platos sucios, apilados sin lavar.
Olemos caca de mascotas.
Escuchamos bebés llorando a los gritos.
Salimos a la calle
y hay chicos deambulando, solos.
¿Nadie los fue a buscar a la escuela?
No es un ataque zombi.
Este apocalipsis podría generarse
si un día las mujeres
nos levantamos y decidimos no hacer
lo que hacemos todos los días.
Desde ver que los hijos, hijas, hijes...
(Aplausos)
se bañen, hagan la tarea,
acompañar a las personas mayores
a las citas médicas,
preparar la comida,
cuidar a los que se enferman.
Cada una de estas tareas
parece muy chiquitita
pero sin ellas la sociedad no funciona.
Es un espacio de producción.
Se llama la economía del cuidado.
Y aunque son tareas
que dejan un valor muy concreto,
hoy no reciben ningún pago.
En todas las casas
se hace este trabajo todos los días,
pero de alguna forma no lo vemos,
es invisible.
Probablemente porque
para nosotros es natural.
Corresponde que cada familia
resuelva el cuidado como pueda
y, en general, se soluciona
con el tiempo de las mujeres.
Es un asunto íntimo.
Los hijos son propiedad de las familias.
"Con mis hijos no te metas", dicen.
O, "Si tuviste hijos, hacete cargo".
Es un asunto tan invisible
que ni siquiera lo vemos
cuando lo tenemos enfrente.
Se habla mucho de los nini, los jóvenes
que no estudian ni trabajan.
Hace ya seis años desde CIPPEC,
haciendo un trabajo
en Provincia de Buenos Aires,
descubrimos que en realidad
tres de cada cuatro jóvenes
que no están trabajando,
estudiando, ni buscando trabajo,
son chicas que tiene a cargo
el cuidado de sus hermanos,
sus abuelos, o sus hijos.
En definitiva, no existen los nini,
existen mujeres cuidadoras.
Las mujeres más pobres
tienen la carga más grande.
Dedican ocho horas y media por día,
un poco más que una jornada
laboral normal, al cuidado.
Tienen que dedicar tanto tiempo
porque en los contextos donde viven
es muchísimo más difícil
gestionar el cuidado.
No hay cloacas, por ejemplo,
entonces los chicos se enferman más
y hay que llevarlos más al hospital.
Si estas mujeres decidieran salir
a trabajar de forma remunerada
los empleos que conseguirían pagan tan mal
que ni siquiera les alcanzaría
para reemplazar
lo que ellas mismas hacen
adentro de sus casas.
Pierden plata saliendo a trabajar.
Y, además, se exponen
a situaciones riesgosas.
Ana, por ejemplo, es de Pampa de
los Guanacos, en Santiago del Estero.
Ella trabajaba en la capital
como empleada doméstica
y había veces que no podía volver
a su casa por semanas enteras,
ni ver a sus hijos.
Ana estaba en la informalidad,
lo cual es muy común.
Todavía hoy tres de cada cuatro personas
que trabajan en el sector del
empleo doméstico no están registradas.
Yo la conocí por un proyecto
y ella me contó que trabajó
muchísimos años en la misma casa.
Ella era como de la familia.
Comía con todos,
la llevaban de vacaciones.
Pero así como en esa casa
a los hijos les pegaban,
a ella también la llegaron a maltratar.
Ana me dijo que ella no quiere nunca más
dejar a sus hijos para ir a trabajar.
¿Por qué querría?
No se trata solamente
de la plata que podría ganar
sino de todo lo que tiene para perder.
Cuando la única opción
es quedarse cuidando,
es mucho más probable que esas familias,
con suerte, tengan un único ingreso,
que encima suele ser bastante más bajo.
Y es así como esas familias
y, en particular esas mujeres,
están en una trampa en la que quedan
atrapados también sus hijos y sus nietos.
Yo veo esta situación
parecida a una estafa piramidal.
Todos ponemos, pero acá en vez
de poner plata se pone tiempo.
Y esperamos que
nos lleguen los beneficios.
Pero todos nos vemos perjudicados
de alguna forma.
Las familias con más ingresos
nos vemos perjudicadas
porque terminamos siendo cómplices
de algo de lo que nadie quiere ser parte.
Se saca ventaja de la situación
de vulnerabilidad en la que vive
una parte importante de la sociedad.
Es una trampa sistémica.
La falta de oportunidades lleva a eso.
Las mujeres con menos ingresos
dan su tiempo
a las familias de clase media y alta
y es por eso que tanto varones
como mujeres de esas familias
podemos salir a trabajar.
Pero a las mujeres más pobres
nadie les da tiempo.
Ellas también tienen que cuidar.
No tienen los recursos.
Y nadie cuida de ellas.
Acá nadie gana.
No es que hay un estafador detrás.
Todos perdemos.
Porque se amplifican
la pobreza y la desigualdad.
Esta situación que parece
un ciclo vicioso, sin salida,
en realidad no tiene por qué ser así.
Podemos romper esta trampa
que deja a familias
por generaciones en la pobreza.
Y hay muchas cosas con las que empezar.
Primero, reconocer el valor que tiene
este trabajo que hacemos las mujeres.
El cuidado está atravesado por el amor
y está lleno de gratificaciones.
Pero no por eso deja de ser un trabajo.
Tenemos que lograr que las mujeres
que trabajan profesionalmente
en el cuidado lo hagan
en buenas condiciones.
Que sea un trabajo digno, bien remunerado,
formal, que les sirva hacerlo.
Para eso es fundamental
que esté mejor representado.
¿Nos imaginamos a una senadora
que sea empleada doméstica?
A las mujeres que cuidan a tiempo completo
en sus propias casas también
hay que reconocerles ese trabajo.
Por ejemplo, incluyendo
en los cálculos de las jubilaciones
los años dedicados
a la crianza y el cuidado.
Formalmente, como se hace en España.
¿Qué pasaría si los varones
toman una parte mayor
de este trabajo de cuidados?
Para que deje de ser una cosa
predominantemente de mujeres.
Personalmente me asusta un poco
cómo la gente
asume que yo voy a saber
qué hacer en dos meses
cuando nazca mi primera hija, Maia.
Y nadie pretende lo mismo de mi marido.
(Aplausos)
Quiero proponerles un ejercicio
ahora a todos los que vinieron hoy.
Quiero pedirles a los varones
que vivan con una mujer,
puede ser cualquier mujer,
puede ser su pareja, su madre,
su hija, una amiga, una hermana,
todos los varones que viven con
una mujer por favor que se paren.
Varios.
Ahora quiero pedirles
a todos los que se pararon
que son un montón
si Uds. no lavaron ropa
en la última semana
y esto incluye usar el lavarropas,
lavar a mano, llevar al Laverap,
si Uds. no cumplieron
esta función, siéntense.
Quedaron algunos, pocos, pero quedaron.
Ahora quisiera pedirles
a los que se sentaron
si Uds. estarían dispuestos
a distribuir estas tareas
de una forma más justa
adentro de sus casas,
por favor, que se vuelvan a parar.
Gracias. Se pueden sentar todos.
Un aplauso, por favor,
a los que participaron.
(Aplausos)
Fotos como esta todavía son raras.
Hay avances, claramente, muchos
son más discursivos que reales.
Esta foto formó parte de una muestra
que montamos en la estación
de trenes de Buenos Aires,
en Retiro, para contribuir al cambio
cultural que tanto se necesita.
Porque ni los varones que quieren
hacer más trabajo de cuidados
y que saben lo que se pierden,
ni la sociedad,
ni el mercado de trabajo,
se los termina de permitir.
Hasta las leyes terminan
diciendo que el cuidado
es responsabilidad de mujeres.
En Argentina, por ejemplo, la licencia
por maternidad es de 90 días.
Y la licencia por paternidad
es de dos días.
Ya hay muchos países que
salieron de esta situación.
No es solo algo que pasa en
las series suecas en Netflix.
Estoy hablando de Uruguay, Ecuador...
En Argentina, con dos días
de licencia por paternidad
les estamos diciendo a los varones
que ellos tienen que cuidar a su trabajo.
Les estamos diciendo a las mujeres
que ellas tienen que cuidar a sus hijos.
Y les estamos diciendo a las empresas
que tienen que contratar varones.
Como sociedad nos pusimos de acuerdo
en que la educación,
la salud, las jubilaciones, son cosas
que queremos hacer entre todos.
Por eso están garantizadas por el Estado.
El cuidado es un pilar
igual de importante.
Pero tenemos tan naturalizado
que es un tema familiar
que las políticas públicas
de cuidado parecen un lujo
que no podemos darnos.
Una mayor inversión en una infraestructura
y en un sistema de cuidados
podría ayudarnos a nivelar la cancha.
Podríamos asegurar
que todos los chicos y chicas
tengan buenas oportunidades.
Desde esos primeros momentos de vida
que son tan esenciales.
También podríamos mejorar las condiciones
de las familias en pobreza
si todos los adultos de esas familias
pudiesen contar con ingresos propios.
Pero ¿de dónde saldrían esos trabajos?
Con unos colegas demostramos
que podrían generarse
a partir de la misma
inversión en cuidados.
Por ejemplo, garantizar
que dos tercios de los chicos
que hoy tienen menos de cuatro años
asista a algún espacio de crianza,
enseñanza o cuidado,
generaría casi
1 300 000 puestos de trabajo.
Poco más de un tercio
de lo que se necesita
para las oportunidades
de los que hoy no tienen.
Se necesitarían personas que trabajen
en la construcción de estos espacios,
que eduquen, que cuiden, que cocinen,
que transporten los alimentos
que se necesitan para cocinar,
que los cultiven...
El efecto es multiplicador.
Estimamos que esto haría crecer
a la economía en 5,3 puntos del PBI
en un período de cuatro años.
¿Quién se hubiese imaginado
que los jardines de infantes
tenían un impacto tan grande
en nuestro desarrollo?
Esta tensión entre el trabajo y el cuidado
me está atravesando muy vívidamente
en los últimos meses.
Pregunto a toda persona que se me acerca
"¿Y vos cómo te organizaste?",
tratando de descifrar cómo se hace esto
de tener hijos y seguir trabajando.
Cuando yo nací mi mamá
también trabajaba todo el día,
casi nazco en su estudio,
y me cuidó mi abuela Clara.
Me encantaba estar con ella.
Sé que mi mamá se muere de ganas,
está desesperada por el amor
que tiene ya por esta futura nieta,
pero sé que no la va a poder cuidar.
Primero, porque sigue trabajando.
Y segundo, porque vive en Bariloche
y yo vivo acá en Buenos Aires.
Mi marido trabaja en un lugar
con muy poca flexibilidad
y tampoco es una opción.
Por suerte mi suegra
se ofreció a cuidarla a Maia
y eso me deja tranquila
porque mi casa no va a caer
en ese apocalipsis doméstico.
Pero, de nuevo, es a costa
del tiempo de otra mujer.
Siempre es a costa
Una mujer de otra generación
o una mujer de otra clase social.
Terminamos perpetuando la trampa.
Yo quiero que rompamos
la trampa invisible.
Quiero que las mujeres seamos
dueñas de nuestro tiempo.
Quiero que todos los chicos y chicas
tengan buenas oportunidades desde
esos primeros momentos de vida.
Y quiero que la pobreza deje de ser
una condena por generaciones.
(Aplausos)
Y sé que podemos hacerlo
porque está demostrado
hace más de 50 años por pioneras
de la economía feminista
que las políticas públicas de cuidado
reducen la pobreza y la desigualdad.
Por eso quiero que haya
más espacios de cuidado,
más jardines de infantes,
que las que cuidan lo hagan
en buenas condiciones,
y que nos pongamos de acuerdo en que esto
es algo que también tenemos
que empujar entre todos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)